would you like to do a potato chip
tasting with me
sure i would
i want you to know that my dog already
started and ate two bowls of potato
chips without me oh my god i love it i
hope i'd love to get your dog's opinion
um
all right
which one do you want to start with
bridgette you lead the really direct
um uh let's start with the one on your
right so that should be
what is that
is it the rotisserie chicken
uh-huh
oh my god
oh
this is the one my dog liked
by the way
that makes a lot i'm just wondering
can we get rotisserie chicken
with like green beans
and maybe a salad mixed in there so i
just have to eat the chips and not the
whole meal
yeah like you know what i mean a tv
dinner chip
i love tv dinners i do too this is weird
i'm not gonna lie what do you think
bridget yay or nay
it's a little much for me
okay next
this one scares me
it's called salted egg
it's what comes out of the chicken
i
don't know if i needed that visual as
i'm putting it in my mouth
tastes like hay
or like the shavings that you put in the
chicken coop
yep
thank you no
all right next we're gonna um
i'm not going with that one
uh-oh
yeah
um
the next step is the
i'm actually excited for this one it
sounds normal ketchup
oh my god
so
i'm kind of like the forest gump when it
comes to potatoes and tomatoes i will
eat them any which way
boiled fried pureed
but i don't like ketchup
you know i'm not a big ketchup person
either i'm i prefer mustard
um but i gotta give it up if you like
ketchup you gotta get these chips i i'll
find out who made them because they are
ketchup in a chip i mean whoa whoever
like was in the lab going we're gonna
make ketchup they did it they mission
accomplished
yeah
i feel like i'm a traditionalist i like
um vinegar
and salt
or just salt well now we're going to try
this this one honey mustard
[Laughter]
oh
bridget thought i have to now i have i
would say no potato chip is safe from me
but i think that
i i wouldn't go after these
i feel like even your dog might walk at
that one
my dog did leave two
jars alone
but she took down two she took down the
mustard and she took down the rotisserie
chicken
well then fit for a queen or a king
yeah a queen i feel like those are the
winners she happens to be allergic to
chicken so i don't know if we're going
to have an issue
i might have an issue alongside of her
after this death so we'll see
[Music]